voilà merci rien et puis propose de
découvrir ces images en direct
celle d'emmanuel macron qui a rejoint
l'esplanade du louvre ce lieu choisi
pour faire la fête mais aussi pour tenir
ce discours le discours du président il
en a déjà tenu un et bien il ya eu une
mise en scène
en tout cas une lumière s'inscrire dans
l'histoire de france en je trouve que
justement vous avez dansé emblématique
de cette histoire je crois qu'il prouve
que là il
c'est la culture ses lacunes sur
l'exacte la france c'est la france 0,6
et la nature des siens comme c'est la
france de françois mitterrand avec il
faut il faut tout assumer
je vous demanderais de regarder ces
images en essayant d'être le cas via
seule cible parce que c'est une image
est évidemment une très forte sans
recueillement mais simplement c'est une
image que l'on vit en direct
on va entendre emmanuel macron dans
quelques instants il a tenu un discours
au qg plus solennelle vous l'avez trouvé
comment elle m'a trop puisqu'on va
l'entendre qu'elle alors montbray très
franc je l'écoutais à la radio grésille
ma voiture en arrivant
moi je l'avais trouvé triste pour tout
vous dire mais lourd de sens n'a pris la
mesure de sa mise en doute
nous en sommes tous david cormand vous
l'avez historiques ont été soumis les
discours j'avoue jupin il a rectifié le
tir de du discours de la retourne
d'avant la rotonde jean-baptiste lemoyne
qui regardait ses images avec beaucoup
d'attention
oui avec d'émotion c'est parce que quand
même c'est quelque chose d'assez
incroyable qu'il a réussi à faire et je
crois que voilà maintenant il faut être
à la hauteur
effectivement délivrés
être dans l'efficacité mais mais le
discours de la semaine dernière était un
discours qui effectivement s'adressaient
aussi beaucoup aux marcheurs à ces
centaines de milliers ils sont 250 agir
c'est un vsab donc est aujourd'hui
s'adresse à tous les français c'est
normal certes des front national c'est
ce qu'il a dit parce qu'il s'y était il
a entendu les craintes les angoisses et
est par exemple sur l'europe je peux
vous dire qu'en matière d'immigration
par exemple il veut remettre les choses
d'aplomb
donc il va renverser la table on va voir
bernard mot no non mais moi je crois pas
un mot des promesses de monsieur macron
ce monsieur là il est commun en charge
du bilan de monsieur hollande il ya
quand même trois si vous l'avez répété
oui mais tout au long de la campagne
c'est le cas donc les français vont
mesurer les conséquences des événements
qui vont survenir dans les semaines qui
vont venir
et là se font en plus de ça moi je
trouve monsieur maintenant assez
infantile dans son mode de
fonctionnement pourquoi pourquoi parce
que ça me fait penser 1
phrase d'ecclésiastes le mal malheur à
toi pays dont
comment dire le roi est un enfant c'est
exactement ce qui me vient à l'esprit
bernard vous allez mesurer les
conséquences bernard monnet aux allées
et vous allez mesurer les conséquences
vous êtes lorsque la mort directe
frappera la france dans quelques
semaines ce trouble voilà emmanuel
macron va s'exprimer dans quelques
bombes maintenant devant la pyramide du
loup créé voulue par françois mitterrand
avec évidemment le louvre rappelons que
c'était de l'ancien siège du ministère
des finances où valéry giscard d'estaing
avait d'ailleurs ses bureaux reste un
lieu évidemment d'armé c'est un chien
aussi un lieu politique
l'action du ministre de monsieur
hollande qui sera son premier ministre
avait déjà eu 100 m
ces hippies tous les manuels mais à
l'écouté vous suivez à s'exprimer et on
essaiera de répondre à cette question
sur le premier ministre évidemment qu
est une question importante
[Applaudissements]